today I'm starting with stunning new
leaked emails internal Fox News emails
that show that Executives knew when we
fact check Trump's election lies it's
bad for business if you are like the
last remaining person on Earth who
doubts whether Fox News is news or overt
profit-driven propaganda we can now put
that uncertainty to rest Fox News CEO
Suzanne Scott in a panic in the
aftermath of the 2020 election saying
we've got to stop these fact checks
telling the truth fact-checking Trump is
really bad for business there are any
number of write-ups about this CNN has
one article by Oliver Darcy and Marshall
Cohen from uh yesterday updated this
well actually from this morning
called Fox News CEO said correspondence
fact check of Trump's election lies was
quote bad for business new emails show
we're going to look at the emails in a
moment the article describes or
characterizes Suzanne Scott as sounding
the alarm about the financial Fallout
that they would suffer
if they keep fact checking Donald
Trump's lies
telling the truth isn't very profitable
when the monster you have created
uh over the last 20 30 years 30 years
doesn't actually want the truth they
want to be spoon fed the lies that their
dear orange leader is perpetuating let's
take a look at a couple of these emails
in this first one this is Fox CEO
Suzanne Scott responding to a segment in
which Fox News is on air Talent Eric
Shawn fact checked a trump falsehood
and Suzanne Scott the CEO writes this
has to stop now this is bad business and
there clearly is a lack of understanding
what is happening in these shows the
audience is furious and we are just
feeding them material bad for business
she's talking about the fact checks the
fact checks are bad for business are we
news where we prioritize the truth or
are we propaganda where we prioritize
whatever lie is most profitable well we
know the answer here's another email
this one is is from Maria Bartiromo one
of the greatest Trump Brown nosers on
that network from November 7th where she
says they need War
they need War uh we have to go to a
full-on war they have used all systems
to defraud hammer or voting zinc the IB
side in the vote total Jare it's it's
crazy Jared says he doesn't want to hear
about any conspiracy theory
everyone us excluding me from meetings
we have to file federal suits in every
state the campaign is not doing s
they want to file lawsuits in a couple
places that's not going to solve the
problem this is Maria Bartiromo
seemingly a True Believer
falling for all of it she writes the
country needs to survive we have to keep
this President no one thinks anyway that
people voted for Biden he lost and we've
seen text messages from Maria and Steve
Bannon before that show they seem to be
true believers they don't seem to
actually just be uh telling what they
know to be lies Maria seems to genuinely
think that Trump won and it's Bonkers
another email
Uh Kevin McCarthy notes Kevin McCarthy
notes this is a pre-interview email
about Kevin McCarthy and
um this is from Maria Bartiromo I guess
to her team where she says you believe
Biden won one Fair there are a few
issues but I don't believe there is a
mass cheat oh wait a second
so she doesn't believe it in another one
I've not seen any proof so far of the
ballot fraud
well so maybe Maria Bartiromo believes
they need to do whatever whatever lie
they need to tell to keep Trump
but doesn't actually believe that there
was the fraud that Trump is alleging and
then Suzanne Scott on November 19th
2020.
saying I can't keep defending these
reporters who don't understand our
viewers this is like the epitome of she
gets what's going on
she says I'm getting major incoming on
her editorializing at the top of Dana's
Show and her dismissive tone and
indifference to the audience she means
not not just playing up The Lies We need
to manage this I saw she just did a
hidden Cavuto I hope she didn't double
down I can't keep defending these
reporters who don't understand our
viewers and how to handle Stories the
audience feels like we crapped on and we
have damaged their trust and belief in
US think about that
fact checking makes Their audience not
trust them she goes on to say we lost 25
000 subscriptions from Fox Nation we can
fix this but we cannot smirk at our
viewers any longer
she is saying our audience doesn't want
truth our audience wants us to keep
fueling the lies that Trump actually won
and this is what Fox News thinks of
Their audience they know our audience
wants lies they don't want fact checks
they don't want truth and it really
distills the entire operation of Fox
News into its immoral and dishonest
essence
stunning stunning revelations in these
emails now we go back to the question
that after the Fox News text message
leaks we asked after it was leaked that
Tucker was saying he hates Trump
passionately is this going to make Fox's
audience turn on them I don't think it
will and when we spoke to Matt Gertz
from Media Matters he also more or less
seemed to say the people who need to
hear about this stuff won't ever know
about it or if they come across it
they'll dismiss the reporting as fake
news they'll say oh David those email
screenshots are obviously doctored we
can't believe that that that those
aren't real no no no no no Fox tells the
truth and the truth is Trump one now Fox
mostly knows that they're lying and they
know that the lies are the best thing
possible for business this is where we
are today it's tragic it's sad I don't
know how we deprogram these people I've
not found a way
but we at least now have it in black and
white and highlighted in yellow as you
saw in those emails Fox knows they're
lying and they know the lies are what's
most profitable for them we're going to
keep delving into the anti-trans Panic
as a result of the shooting in Nashville
Tennessee but one of the things that is
front of mind for me and there's a very
good Vice news article about this is
that the trans identity of the Nashville
Tennessee shooter despite the fact that
what
three or four out of the last 5 000 Mass
Shooters have been not even necessarily
trans either non-binary or trans like
four out of five thousand okay despite
that all of a sudden
the right Wingers are seeing the trans
identity of the Nashville shooter as the
opening to declare full-scale war
against the trans Community I'm
extraordinarily concerned about our
trans friends and allies because I do
believe that they are at serious risk
like it's not an exaggeration I think
that there this is this is an over
threat we are now seeing uh for for
several years now to be perfectly honest
I have pointed out to you that at events
like CPAC and others the biggest
Applause lines even at Trump rallies the
biggest Applause lines come during the
anti-trans moments of speeches when Ted
Cruz says my pronouns are kiss my ass
and everybody stands in cheers and Trump
says we must not allow teachers to teach
transgender without parental consult I
mean consent
and the crowd cheers and they go crazy
um this has been building for a while
and it's now open season Vice news
writing the right is using the Nashville
shooting to declare war on trans people
it has been an online barrage towards
basically any visible trans person
online Tucker Carlson did a segment in
which he claims that the trans Community
is actually targeting Christians we're
going to talk about that separately I
don't even want to delve into that now
because it really deserves its own
segment but as the article says as soon
as details started to emerge about the
shooter in Nashville pundits and
politicians on the Right started
exploiting the tragedy to spread
anti-trans hate you know almost every
Mass shooter is a young white male not
all of them but most of them you look at
the last 5 000 mass shootings like I
said it's overwhelmingly young white men
and so when that is the case
all of a sudden many of these right-wing
networks and people have nothing to say
they have nothing to say now to a
certain extent when their Kyle kolinsky
said this yesterday in a great video
which I'll talk about later that he did
about my controversy related to the
shooting he said you know these
shootings are so common that like when
three people are killed in a shooting
we all say do we talk about is this a
story because there's like three of
these A Day in the United States is this
a story and for many of these right
Wingers when it is the what we call it
imagine we have like our traditional
mass shooting in the U.S young white
male
gets an AR-15 maybe also a handgun and
goes crazy and starts shooting people
either because of we've seen every we've
seen everything disgruntled employment
employment stuff targeting a particular
race we've seen all of it we've seen all
of it is it even a story and it isn't
always a story and a lot of the right
Wingers don't even comment
all of a sudden
the trans identity of this individual is
exposed and reported on and every right
winger wants to talk about it this is
the important mass shooting to talk
about never mind that there have been I
mean if we want to be precise what is
the uh let's see how many mass shootings
have there already been since this one
um oh I don't have an updated list okay
oh wait last 72 hours
uh so let's see one two there's been a
bunch of mass shootings since this one
but they want to talk about the one with
the Trans shooter and the most important
takeaways of course are that these are
people who don't actually want to do
anything about guns their priority if
they do talk about a shooting or if they
don't talk about a shooting it's to
serve their primary purpose which is
don't deal with guns don't look at
implementing any of the 10 ideas that I
presented to you yesterday one trans
person
versus how how many non-trans mass
Shooters so transgenderism must be the
problem drag shows which don't have
anything to do with it must be the
problem all of them have guns but the
guns aren't the problem
oh but mental illness is the problem but
we don't want to commit any money to
treating Mental Illness but now that the
the shooter is trans then we must spread
transphobia we must spread anti-lgbt
sentiment in general and it's disturbing
and it's depressing Marjorie Taylor
green particularly disgusting she is
calling for Trans Vengeance she has been
suspended from Twitter and we will talk
about that separately again because I
believe it's its own form of evil which
we will discuss and of course then we
always go back to
when people like me say hey
I've had a proposal with 10 different
Provisions to deal with some of the gun
aspects of this I've had the proposal
for for years David it's too soon to
politicize the tragedy we must not make
it political
really when we actually want to look at
solutions to the problem it's too soon
but it is never too soon to spread hate
and to say well drag time story hour is
what caused this what and I don't even
want to go into this yet because there's
a lot of allegations flying around but
what really may be at issue here what
really may be at issue here is the
treatment of the individual
and who ultimately did this
at that school and we're still learning
more about that and and hopefully at
some point we will know the full story
but it is open season on the trans
Community we all need to be extremely
concerned about this and we're going to
continue talking about it more make sure
you're subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show so
much coming up on the program today
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a
12-month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
well if you thought the hate mob
yesterday was going to stop with Donald
Trump Jr and Candace Owens
that's bad enough by the way it didn't
last night Sean Hannity Fox News
propagandist took a break from
interviewing Donald Trump in order to
direct the hate mob against me and it
led to yet another round of insane
threats and anti-Semitism anti-Semitism
which by the way the daily wires Michael
Knowles says I made up which in five
minutes I will show you is sadly very
much not made up but let's not start
with that right now Sean Hannity jumping
on the bandwagon and attacking me but
interestingly he doesn't even actually
quote me or show my tweet
he quotes someone talking about my tweet
what kind of production value is this
how pathetic they couldn't even be
bothered take a look at this didn't stop
there one awful Progressive talk show
host quote joking about the victims not
praying enough that's supposed to be
funny I thought attacking one's personal
religious beliefs was not allowed in the
leftist woke world we live in yeah so up
on the screen is a quote by someone
named Kendall tits or she's Kendall
teets I have to admit I don't actually
know how it's How It's pronounced and it
says it's a quote from Kendall
Progressive talk show host David packman
mocked the Covenant School Community for
not praying enough of course that's not
what I did I pointed out that prayers
don't work to stop mass shootings
Hannity can't even be bothered to show
the Tweet he just goes I don't know I'll
quote Kendall teets or Kendall tits what
the hell is wrong with these people and
of course another wave of anti-Semitism
always Focus on me being Jewish and by
the way by the way by the way uh I'm
going to talk about the anti-Semitism
stuff in a moment but you know but I I
received a lot of messages of support
overnight and I'm going to talk about
some of those a little bit later
unless you are on the receiving end of
the sort of barrage that these
right-wing people do it is every
platform it's a thousand posts on
Instagram
it's a thousand emails it's a hundred
thousand tweets directed at you one a
second
you step away for a half hour and look
and then there's thousands more just
endless endless these
borderline riotous mobs that are in the
audience of folks like Sean Hannity so
there it is Hannity jumping in on the
action creating another barrage and now
what I want to get oh and by the way
so many people signing up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
cancel canceled these people like
Hannity and others they claim to be
against canceling and yet now for 48
hours they've been running campaigns to
try to get me canceled by writing to my
advertisers the number of people I am
flattered and I will delve into this
later who did go to joinpakman.com after
I mentioned it yesterday and signed up
using the coupon code cancel cancel like
cancel the cancelers
stunning numbers and we're going to get
to that a little bit later there's this
guy named Michael Knowles from the daily
wire some of you know him as the daily
wire third Stringer behind Matt Walsh
and Ben Shapiro anyway I've been on his
show before
I stopped going on his show because
nothing positive came from it it doesn't
doesn't have a big enough audience that
it actually did anything for me
but I would get a barrage of
anti-Semitic messages from his viewers
that very same Michael Knowles
thought yesterday to say you know what
David pakman is making up that he's
getting anti-semitic emails and threats
as a result of his tweet here is what
Michael Knowles had to say and of course
there's always this very you know his
background is in acting there's always
this overly dramatic acting that he's
doing he's just so upset so upset by my
tweet there was the most vile reaction
that I've seen to the shooting in
Nashville it was from someone who's
appeared on this show actually he's a
liberal but he's appeared on this show
yeah and it's it's just so hideous yeah
but and I bring it up not even just to
castigate this guy right but but to show
you how wrong the the libs thinking is
in fact our thinking is a thousand
percent right
in that
the thoughts and the prayers do nothing
and the Republicans don't want to do
anything other than that the thinking is
a hundred percent right how pervasive
this kind of vile thinking is but also
how wrong it is sure
uh David packman yeah tweet it out quote
very surprising that there would be a
mass shooting at a Christian School
given that lack of prayer is often
blamed for these horrible events it is
possible they weren't praying enough or
correctly isn't this just like obvious
despite being a Christian School
yeah they send thoughts and prayers
and there's a shooting at a place where
people are praying obviously the elected
officials
who only send thoughts and prayers are
horrible people unwilling to actually do
anything to solve this problem what's so
complicated about that
that is the most vile tweet I've ever
read
can you imagine has he ever does he
remember when Trump was on Twitter the
most vile tweet so the hyperbole is
going a little far I have to say
and Twitter is a cesspool
for the most vile kinds of speech you
can imagine that's true now that's true
if you have any kind of public profile
at all you've seen you've seen plenty of
vile stuff directed at you or yeah
much of it that is much of it from his
audience the single most vile tweet I
have ever read really it must be very
sheltered he ended up deleting it but he
didn't apologize well no I mean people
deliberately misconstrued it to send a
hate mob against me why would I
apologize it's accurate the thoughts and
prayers didn't prevent the shooting and
our elected officials need to do more
and they're unwilling to
in fact he played the victim he said all
right too many anti-semitic attacks and
threats to my family I've deleted the
tweet
so we wanted let's
one no one saw any of these alleged
anti-semitic attacks or what a what a
joker yeah so anyway
um the anti-semitic attacks
check a couple things on this
I don't want to like highlight too many
of these anti-semitic attacks and
threats because it just fuels more of
them but now that someone is prominent
as Michael Knowles
is saying suggesting there are no such
things
uh I have to at least say something
about it first of all check out the
comments just look through the comments
I won't even put them up
check out the comments on the video I
did about this uh the video
um wherein I said a million people are
angry at me my tweet pissed off a
million people
um just scroll through the comments half
of the comments
are overtly anti-submitic comments it's
like a Neo-Nazi KKK meeting
in the comments to the point where
YouTube contacted me and said listen
this is like Beyond just reporting
individual comments because it's it's
just it's all anti-semitic YouTube
doesn't know how to handle the comments
on my YouTube channel because they are
so anti-semitic and I don't know what
Michael Knowles would accept as proof
check out my inbox again a thousand of
these and also some sent to family
members whose contact info these people
found I'm just going to give you three
examples again because I I want to show
you that these are very real but also
not spend all day showing you these one
person wrote to me calling me a filthy
anti-white k word k word for Jew which I
don't know if it's allowed on radio so
I'm not going to say it and says you're
a rat-faced anti-white k word Who
belongs in Israel I've been to Israel
once for 10 days
someday Jews will have their citizenship
stripped and they will be banned from
holding positions in American government
media Academia and law white people are
simply sick of your Jewish degeneracy
and it's time for Jews to pack up and
leave this is one of a thousand okay
Michael Noel says these don't exist
here's reality Michael Knowles lives in
a fantasy world
we have reality and we have fantasy here
Michael knows lives in fantasy this is
the reality one out of a thousand that I
got second one again just just a
sampling
Jewish from someone who goes by groiper
way to mock the murder of Christians
effing k word k word for Jews okay and
third
F you dumb c word often used for women
have fun in Hell Jew boy Christ is King
Holocaust didn't happen by the way
okay I could do a live stream
all day just reading these they come in
faster than they can be read
if you look at Twitter Youtube my email
inbox Facebook and Instagram
Michael null says the the anti-semitic
messages don't exist they come in at a
rate of more than one every few seconds
okay so that's the truth but Michael
Knowles and others want you to think
there are none and by the way I stopped
doing his show
because every time I was on it
I would get anti-semitic emails it just
wasn't worth it because it wasn't
helping me build my audience it was only
generating hate these people are truly
dangerous and they're depraved but after
the break I'm going to tell you the good
of the last 24 hours
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
my friends I have to tell you I am
flattered I'm humbled I'm grateful I I
don't even know what word to use for the
stunning outpouring of Support over the
last 24 hours after I communicated to
you the existential threat to the David
packman show as a result of the right
wing mob sent after me by Donald Trump
Jr and by Sean Hannity and Candace Owens
and everybody which included trying to
bully our advertisers into pulling their
support for my show because I had the
audacity to tweet that thoughts and
prayers don't stop shootings even at a
Christian School where they pray all the
time and that something must be done
they pretended not to realize that I'm
obviously not blaming the dead children
and they activated and it has been an
insane 48 hours so first of the bad news
this is just it's not good
some advertisers have pulled their
support period they don't want to hear
reason I'm not going to tell you which
ones because I don't want you to now go
and Target them right I mean but but you
will notice that some advertisers are
going to be gone from our videos over
the next immediate period of time
but
check out the response from a couple of
our advertisers one who said publicly
they have to be neutral so please don't
say who we are but they said in response
to us saying listen here's what's going
on
they said quote we advocate for free
speech therefore we are not concerned
with David's comments we would prefer to
continue the partnership and stand up to
those who are looking to destroy freedom
of speech
we also
uh have a second Advertiser that wrote
to Noah Noah handles our all of our ads
and says I've been monitoring the
situation and while we're seeing some
emails both in opposition to and in
support of David it's nothing too crazy
no emails from any of our actual
customers though they all claim to be
and this is as I've said
the people trying to get us canceled
with our advertisers they're not my
viewers and they're also not the
customers of any of our advertisers this
Advertiser went on to say
personally I'm so incredibly tired of
the outrage economy discourse that now
thrives on social media and those like
Miss Owens Candace Owens that promote it
the mob mentality has fully taken hold
if these people were even half as mad
about the constant school shootings as
they are about a now deleted tweet maybe
there would be some progress on the
issue just like every faux outrage event
I'm sure this will all blow over in a
few days once there is something new for
people to complain about appreciate you
putting our ads on hold for a bit we
told our advertisers we won't run
anything for the rest of this week
because we don't want all of your the
videos with your ads to be filled with
anti-submitic comments appreciate
putting the ads on hold for a bit we've
been really happy with our sponsorship
of David's show and look forward to
working with him in the future
that is inspiring to see from
advertisers who see this for what it is
we also saw some really great videos
published by our friends and colleagues
Kyle Kolinski and Jesse dollimore Kyle
put out a video called Candace Owens
attacks David Pacman where Kyle
brilliantly breaks down the obviously
contrived right-wing mob over an obvious
tweet about how thoughts and prayers
don't stop shootings Jesse dollamore put
out a video called David Pacman is being
attacked by Donald Trump Jr and other
right-wing ghouls where he also espouses
total moral and factual clarity about
the situation but even more important we
love Jesse and Kyle but even more
important is all of you
look at the response from all of you I
asked you please subscribe to the
YouTube channel because imagine the
message we would send
to this targeted right-wing mob by
coming out of this with a bigger YouTube
channel and you did more than 5 000 of
you subscribe to the YouTube channel
just yesterday and it's already on fire
today
thank you I asked you email our
advertisers tell them stick with David
that is actual viewers support you
hundreds of you cc'd me on thousands of
emails to advertisers
nearly 50 people started new patreon
pledges at patreon.com davidpackman show
another 40 of you signed up for the
premium newsletter via sub stack but
listen to this that I I I'm a big strong
guy but I almost have tears in my eyes
as Donald Trump would say
over 700 new website members in the last
24 hours we created this coupon code
exactly to track this the code is cancel
cancel the idea is cancel the counselors
cancel cancel and that code works at
joinpakman.com
as of 9 A.M this morning
478 new members signed up with that code
and over 700 new members in total a
couple hundred of you didn't even use
the code you paid full price and if I
look right now
they're coming in one every two minutes
it is unbelievable
so listen The Advertiser losses are
significant I can't will that away it's
just the reality
but some of our advertisers see this for
what it is
the new memberships are helping to
offset those losses and maybe most
importantly those YouTube subscriber
growth numbers are really a signal that
my actual audience not the people who
now are coming oh I used to love your
show now our actual audience gets the
whole point of this
thoughts and prayers don't stop mass
shootings whether it's at a Christian
school or a secular school that's really
what this is about so thank you
keep subscribing keep the memberships
going I can't tell you how much I
appreciate it and come Monday we'll see
where everything stands but what a 48
Hours let's now get back to the really
important stuff that's going on at the
top of the show we talked about a Vice
news article which accurately and
correctly outlines
how there is now an open season on the
trans Community as a result of the
shooter in the Nashville Tennessee
shooting uh being a trans individual now
this of course ignores that if you look
at the last 5 000 mass shootings there
have been like three or four trans or
non-binary Shooters ignores all facts in
reality that a drag show where stories
are read to kids not necessarily by
trans people just by drag performers
has nothing to do with what took place
in Nashville Tennessee doesn't matter
it's now open season and one of the
primary perpetrators
here is radical repugnant and
reactionary Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green or Marjorie green
Taylor or Marjorie Trader green
depending on your preference she has now
been suspended from Twitter after a
warning about trans vengeance
Newsweek reports
representative Marjorie Taylor green
claimed that her Congressional Twitter
account has been suspended after sharing
unfounded information about a trans day
of Vengeance in the wake of the
Nashville school shooting
as you know the shooter ultimately
killed at least six people including
three young students and three adult
faculty members
police have yet to officially disclose a
probable motive they've confirmed the
shooter identified as trans although it
remains unclear in which ways and to
what degree it was the case nevertheless
several prominent conservative figures
like green have attempted to link Hale's
actions to being trans insinuating with
little evidence that gender transition
drugs or surgeries were to blame in some
manner
Green in particular tweeted about a
supposed event called the trans day of
Vengeance linking it to the Nashville
shooting and alleging a broader threat
of trans-terrorism later green claimed
her personal on her personal account
that her Congressional account was
suspended because of those tweets
the original tweet and subsequent ones
have been deleted but Newsweek was able
to view some of them
after three thousand retweets of this
tweet my account was suspended again why
is Twitter whitewashing the trans day of
Vengeance Elon Musk
a day after a murder of children by a
trans shooter people need to know about
the threat they face from antifa and
transterrorism
in her own post on the matter Ella Irwin
who's the VP of trust and safety at
Twitter said the platform automatically
swept for tweets containing a poster for
the trans day of Vengeance and took him
down no matter who was sharing it or why
makes sense Marjorie Taylor green
shouldn't get special treatment on
Twitter because she's an elected
official
we had we had to automatically sweep our
platform and remove more than 5 000
tweets slash retweets of this poster we
do not support tweets that incite
violence irrespective of who posts them
Vengeance does not imply peaceful
protest organizing or support for
peaceful protests is okay
later responding to a claim from Irwin
that accounts were not receiving strikes
for sharing at Green share to screenshot
of an explanation she purportedly
received and said this is a lie
um she posts saying that she's been
limited because of some of the things
she posted whatever
listen
seeing the right wing rush to spread
transphobia
and more generally the anti-lgbt
sentiment
since the shooting earlier this week
it's disturbing and it's depressing but
it's also horrifying of course Marjorie
Taylor green is a particularly
disgusting and abhorrent person I would
argue even by the standards of the
average of the Republican Party you've
got what I consider to be the more
honest actors in the Republican party
people like Willard Mitt Romney Adam
kinsinger Liz Cheney people with whom I
disagree on policy and who certainly
hold some views I find disgusting
including for example on abortion but
they are at least more honest actors in
the Republican party that would call
them on the better side of the
Republican party then you've kind of got
the middle the average of the crazies
and the people like Romney and Cheney
Etc
and then you have people like Marjorie
Taylor green
Matt Gates Lauren bobert Lauren bobert
all of you know all of these types of
folks Marjorie Taylor green even by the
average of the modern Republican party
is particularly disgusting and as always
is the case and I mentioned this earlier
and it Bears repeating again
it's always too soon to politicize
shootings
when it's the typical shooting and what
I mean by that is
white male Born in the USA
under age 25.
then it's too soon to politicize and any
discussion of actually doing a damn
thing about what's going on is
inappropriate when we try to find actual
Solutions when we say hey you know what
had there been a waiting period and had
the person been unable to buy
high-capacity magazines because of their
age or all of the different things that
I talk about 10 different proposals then
this shooting either wouldn't have
happened or fewer people would have died
both of which would be better than what
we oh that David that's too soon how
dare you how dare you uh politicize a
tragedy before they've even buried their
dead well when we wait then nothing
happens
and the NRA does its thing and they do
their dog and pony show and nothing
happens well as we are seeing now they
don't actually care about politicizing
these tragedies too soon because
Marjorie Taylor green and Tucker Carlson
and the whole lot of them
immediately politicized it when it was
about clamping down on the trans
community and linking this to what they
call trans women in sports and drag
shows and CRT and all of this sort of
stuff as always they claim to care about
the deficit but they don't they only
care about the deficit when it's a
democrat in the White House they claim
to care about uh election Integrity
except when they try to steal an
election that they lost it's all
projection and similarly they care about
not politicizing mass shootings
except when it's convenient to
politicize a mass shooting the Trump
says at his rallies there has never been
a movement like this
and he's right but there has never been
a movement this depraved
and uh I am fearful of what comes next
let me know your thoughts and we will
follow up on this for sure
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's keep going today so much to uh to
pack into today's program we're not
going to spend a lot of time on this
last night not only did Sean Hannity go
after me and direct the right wing
contrived hate mob against me he also
aired another portion of his interview
with the failed former president Donald
Trump and this is this is a short clip
it's really just the epitome of what
I've been telling you for years Trump
loves dictators Trump is impressed by
dictators Trump thinks dictators are big
strong guys and the entire thing and
Sean Hannity did this thing which I mean
it's just a complete and total backfire
it's really unbelievable where he lists
different dictators and authoritarians
to Trump and says tell me the first
thing that comes to mind and with every
single one of them what comes to mind is
how great Trump gets along with them
it's you know if if seven years ago I
had told you we're gonna have a former
president who when asked about dictators
and authoritarian strongman just goes I
got along really well I don't know got
along really well I don't know you
wouldn't have believed it but that's
where we are look at this orange
nightmare right
gonna give names and give me quick
short sentence of narratives by the way
Trump just so sweaty eyes almost swollen
shut never clear why what why is it so
hot I don't know whatever comes to your
mind Putin
well I'm gonna have to go a little short
but uh I got along with him great uh
I've been president he would have been
much better off because he wouldn't have
gone into Ukraine yeah the The Reason by
the way this entire thing they keep
repeating
why did Putin wait for Joe Biden to go
into Ukraine Putin had every reason to
think that he wouldn't have to invade in
order to get more territory with Trump
as president if Trump gets another four
years Putin can probably get away with
taking more land in other ways that
doesn't require what he is now doing
it's such a laughable talking boy okay
so there's Putin we're gonna keep going
but ultimately he's going to take over
all of Ukraine we know right especially
if you have a say chi uh a man I got
along again I get along with him great
until code came in we would have been
able to work together very well I got I
made an unbelievable deal for our
farmers and manufacturers where China
was giving us 50 billion dollars a year
to our farmers and our manufacturing got
along great with she
sorry and I stepped over that he says
Kim Jong-un because 50 billion dollars a
year to our farmers and our
manufacturers
uh again got along with them great
people don't want to hear that a lot of
people say that's terrible to get along
with him great when somebody has nuclear
weapons that can blow up the world it's
nice to get along I get along with them
great so listen there are two sides to
this okay let me I I really want to be
this is such a microcosm of the entire
Trump Fiasco on foreign policy that we
have to do both sides there's the simple
side okay the simple side is
Trump is impressed by authoritarians
it's not just Putin and she and Kim
Jong-un
who he believes everything they say and
you know we'll get to that it's also
erdogan
it's Orban
it's bolsonaro it's okay it's all of
them part of it is Trump is just
impressed with them constitutionally
just who they are what they represent
how they behave Trump is in some cases
jealous of them that they have Trump
perceives them to have a gravitas that
he doesn't have but would like to so
there's that side of it but there's
another side of it that's important as
well
it's easy to get along with people who
don't see you as a threat in any way
most of those leaders saw Trump for the
bumbling buffoon that he was and when
you're seen that way there's no reason
to have conflict or a tense relationship
or disagreements or whatever the case
may be because they don't take you
seriously enough to see you as a threat
you're you're not credible enough you're
not Alpha enough to use their version of
what they are talking right
why would you have trouble getting along
with someone who sees you as a doofus
you wouldn't and that's the other side
of it now we can apply this really
specifically for example with Kim
Jong-un
going back decades
in general
it's not that the North Korean leader
wasn't willing to meet with an American
president it's that the American
Presidents didn't see the point of
meeting with the North Korean leaders
without some preconditions why when you
consider the status difference between
an American president and a North Korean
dictator that leads the country the
North Korean dictator is always willing
to get the photo op to get the
propaganda value of meeting with an
American president to then show their uh
population look we're on the world stage
and we told that President and blah blah
blah
it's not difficult to get a meeting with
a North Korean leader if you're an
American president Trump was so clueless
that when he convinced Kim Jong-un to
meet with him he acted like it was an
accomplishment this is why he gets along
with these dictators because they see
Trump they go wow this guy doesn't even
understand why it is that normally they
wouldn't even meet with me at the
meeting
Kim Jong-un made the same promises to
Trump that every North Korean leader has
made in the past to American Presidents
which they have no intentions of keeping
will demilitarize this and we'll do that
and we'll provide this other thing Trump
doesn't know anything so Trump thinks
look at all of these great promises I
got these are the same promises that
they've been making for decades they
will do 10 of it in order to get food
Aid and then ignore the other ninety
percent it's not an accomplishment so
again it's easy to get along with people
who are just walking all over you in
every way because you're so clueless but
anyway so the whole point of it is a
very sweaty very swollen Trump
in this interview able to say nothing
other than I got along with these guys
really well of course you did
also insane over the last 24 hours there
is a new Rolling Stone report Trump
asking advisors for battle plans to
attack Mexico if re-elected this is
truly horrifying he probably watched an
episode of narcos Mexico and was like I
should get some plans to invade the
article reads Trump and his magnified
Republican party are pushing plans for
military action against drug cartels in
Mexico with or without the Mexican
government's consent
Trump is asking for a plan to wage war
in Mexico
and the Republican party is eager to
give it to him Trump has been asking
policy advisors for Military options to
take on Mexican drug cartels including
doing strikes not sanctioned by Mexico's
government according to two sources
familiar with the situation attacking
Mexico or whatever you'd like to call it
is something that President Trump has
said he wants battle plans drawn for
says a source he's complained about
missed opportunities of his first term
and there are a lot of people around him
who want fewer missed opportunities in a
second term listen to this Trump
lieutenants imagine having lieutenants
Trump lieutenants have briefed him on
several options that include unilateral
military strikes and Troop deployments
on a sovereign U.S partner and neighbor
can you imagine the United States
unilaterally deploying troops in Mexico
this is exact you know when we talk
about
Trump wanting to Nuke a hurricane Trump
not understanding why considering using
nukes on Europe is insane this is the
sort of stuff we're talking about this
is the really dangerous stuff
um one such proposal that Trump has been
briefed on is a white paper from the
center for renewing America which is
increasingly influential and it's
staffed by Trump wonks and magaloyalists
and it's called it's time to wage war on
transnational drug cartels this is all
so insane so insane what they should do
is come to Trump you know these big
strong guys they should go to Trump With
Tears in their eyes and say sir
the wall you built it's so powerful that
we can no longer invade Mexico the wall
is too tall for us to invade and attack
Mexico we can't do it this is an example
of the dangerous nature of another Trump
presidency because he will be even more
unhinged the Counterpoint is
Trump's not really going to do this but
Ron DeSantis if he were the president
might actually do some really dangerous
stuff I can see it both ways I really
can but these are horrifyingly dangerous
ideas I have a little old-fashioned
cringe for you radical and repugnant
reactionary Republican congresswoman
Lauren bobert is very concerned about
public urination but so much so that she
ended up making a complete and total
fool of herself during a recent hearing
there's a little write-up in uh Rolling
Stone about this Lauren bobert obsesses
over public urination at crime hearing
Lauren bobert waylaid a congressional
hearing on crime in Washington D.C
by grilling DC city council member
Charles Allen on what she insisted were
efforts to decriminalize public
urination it turns out that he didn't
actually do that you have to see this
clip this is unbelievable and the guy is
increasingly visibly confused because he
doesn't know what the hell she's talking
about
check this out and uh these charges
these changes
are now law here in D.C correct
do you mean the revised criminal code
yes uh no those are not the law okay
first question was this is now the law
answer it is not the law not the law
did with the either
code was uh rejected by excuse me Mr
chairman I'm talking to Mr Allen Mr
Allen did you or did you not
decriminalize public urination in
Washington D.C did you lead the charge
to do so no it the revised criminal code
left that as a criminal charge did you
suanimous but she keeps going the charge
to decriminalize public urination in
Washington DC no ma'am did you ever vote
in favor of decriminalizing public
urination in Washington DC the revised
criminal code did you ever support kept
it as a criminal offense did you did and
you support this criminal I voted for it
yeah you voted
[Music]
this is going so wrong and it's
absolutely delightful keep it as a
criminal offense that's correct
wait so you're telling me
you never advocated to make public
urination not a crime you never voted to
make it not a crime and you voted to
keep it a crime yes hmm interesting that
now I'm now I'm not sure
Congress is devolving rapidly you know
it I
I think we as a community of the left
we expected that when Republicans took
over the House of Representatives it
would become a circus Sideshow I think
we expected that but the degree to which
it has become a circus side show is
genuinely surprising even to me and I've
been I've been doing this you know quite
a long time
um after the fourth time she brings up
public urination
I probably would have lost it if I was
in that room and it is just stunning and
the takeaway here is
well I don't know what the takeaway here
is if Lauren bobert
is thinking about urinating in public
which I guess is a concern for her it is
still a crime
um these people are genuinely a joke and
we laugh just to a certain degree to
avoid crying but I get emails from
European viewers all the time in fact
let me see if I can pull one up uh I'm
not even sure
you're I'm not even sure how I'm going
to be able to do this
anyway I get so many emails from people
saying David what is happening in your
country here's just one as an example
I'm going to just read this I don't want
to put the person I didn't blank it out
um from the Netherlands someone wrote in
and said David I I am encouraging you on
your quest to educate people in the
United States what on Earth is going on
your thoughts and Visions are clearly
needed in the United States it is a
crisis what is wrong with so many
Americans I was brought up with the
United States as a role model now the
United States is a joke barely anything
positive is connected to the United
States particularly because of the
Republican party we increasingly see the
USA negatively because of these lunatics
I understand that this is not your
movement but it is a direct result of
the populistic rhetoric that you
criticize being misused by the
Republican party and these complete and
total clowns most people here did like
Barack Obama but Trump was ridiculed and
now it seems as though there is no
turning back this is just an example
okay that's rhymed from uh from the
Netherlands from Amsterdam every single
day we are a global laughing stock and
it's not just anecdotally it's reflected
in public opinion polls about how people
see the United States and how people see
the office of the presidency we've got
to do something to turn it around and
another four years of trump isn't going
to turn it around and certainly four
years of Ron DeSantis won't either we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P
we got a great voicemail of support
we already talked earlier about all of
the insane things happening Sean Hannity
Donald Trump Jr Candice Owen sending the
right wing mob against me we talked
about what's going on with advertisers
some advertisers sticking with us some
advertisers bailing etc etc
here's just a single message and I got a
ton of these a single message of support
from a viewer
David my name is Steve and I'm calling
just to tell you to hang in there be
encouraged
uh you're going to come out on top of
this and I will support you in any way
that I can thank you been listening to
you for a long time
um
I've never had any problem with what
I've heard you say
uh I think you're pretty right on pretty
sharp and I get a kick out of you
sometimes okay thank you David we need
you we need you don't be discouraged
thank you I can't tell you how much I
appreciate that a powerful message of
support against the hate mob so where do
we stand right now the antagonistic
messages have started to slow down to
some degree instead of a message once a
second it's now like every 15 seconds
now that doesn't sound I know it doesn't
sound that great
it's like David that that's good every
15 seconds it is better than what it was
and we will see where we are by the time
Monday lands I told you we lost a couple
advertisers I I don't know where we're
going to land but I I hope that
uh this caller is is exactly correct we
have such a great bonus show for you
today
a rift in the Republican Party
has been exposed as senators are warning
Kevin McCarthy against this Iraq vote
that is being discussed we're going to
discuss what's going on who might vote
which way and what Republican senators
are up to the FDA in the United States
has approved the over-the-counter sale
of Narcan which is an overdose reversal
drug this is widely seen as a great
thing while some are concerned that it
will
encourage overdosing because hey you can
just grab over-the-counter Narcan and
have it with you we will talk about both
sides of the discussion and Adidas or
Adidas as some of our friends pronounce
it has retracted their opposition to the
black lives matter three stripe design
what is this about what's the back story
what's the controversy I will tell you
all about it on today's bonus show
two great ways to access the bonus show
first and foremost sign up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money there
that was just bad sir yes sir sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code cancel cancel that's all one word
cancel cancel meaning cancel the
cancelers trying to cancel us right now
second option you make a pledge on
patreon of at least five bucks a month
you can find that at patreon.com slash
davidpackman show we will see you on the
bonus show and I will be back tomorrow
with the Friday show
foreign